[Musique]
tu es plus proche que nous n'avons jamais été
agent contractuel ou lionne lionne
nous localisons les épouses et les filles de
ces cibles de grande valeur tu l'as fait je t'ai
dit que je venais je veux dire place un
agent près d'eux et nous  tuez la
cible
si nous jouons ce droit c'est fini avant que
ça ne commence il n'y a vraiment aucun moyen d'
avorter ils la feront tuer et exposeront
l'ensemble du programme notre atout est intégré
nous n'avons pas la capacité de l'
annuler
donc nous '  Je vais juste prétendre qu'une
force de réaction rapide de la CIA n'a pas exécuté
une mission de mise à mort devant CBS News,
expliquez-nous votre décision d'appeler
la frappe de drone, il était mort de toute façon,
vous devez vous rappeler pour quoi vous vous
battez